J'ai peut-être raté mon tour de magie une fois , mais je ne le raterai pas deux fois. Okay ?
Regardez bien, cette balle ne va jamais ré-attérir.
Voilà...
Vous pouvez attendre longtemps. Cherchez pas
ça réatterira pas ! Bon alors la chaise, on est bon.
Putain !!
Les amis, aujourd'hui on va parler d'une théorie
qui est Géniale ! Je l'aime et celle-là
j'en ai entendu parler beaucoup de fois en plus de ça.
Et......
C'est bien de la merde !
Nan, c'est pas de la merde : il est vrai on peut y croire,
on peut ne pas y croire... Mais je pense que
il est plus facile de ne pas y croire que d'y croire !
Mais on y va !! Dans cette histoire,
on va parler un petit peu des Illuminatis...!
Tout le monde connaît les Illuminatis,
ils nous gouvernent en secret, ils controlent les médias.
Aujourd'hui, on va pas parler des Illuminatis en général, mais
on va parler d'une branche spécifique des Illuminatis :
la branche du clonage !!
J'adore faire ce genre de vidéos !
Vous avez peut-être surement vu sur le net :
Beyoncé serait morte dans un accident et un clone la remplacerait.
Et Avril Lavigne pareil...
Paul McCartney aussi ! Pourquoi les Illuminatis
iraient cloner
des gens ?! Pourquoi ?!
Laissez-moi vous parlez de Donald
Marshall ou plutôt de ce qui dit : en 2011,
il a publié un énorme post
sur Facebook, qui a fait un buzz total !
Dans ce long pavé, il dévoile être
lui-même un clone.
Woaahhh... Donald Marshall,
tu commences bien, tu nous intéresses fort : raconte un peu la suite
parce qu'on a envie d'y croire à ton histoire.
Il a eu la malchance de se retrouver dans une station
de clonage dirigé par qui ? Par qui ??
Nan... Quelqu'un qui pèse plus...
Encore... Encore...Et...OUI !!!
La reine Elisabeth II ! Marshall aurait été vendu
aux Illuminatis par ces parents qui étaient en dèche
quand il avait l'âge de cinq ans. Certains
deviennent serveurs pour arrondir leurs fins de mois. D'autres vendent
leur enfants aux Illuminatis : c'est bon. Selon Marshall,
les Illuminatis se rencontrent généralement dans des bunkers
souterrains. Et toujours selon Marshall, il y a certains
bunkers qui cachent des fermes à clones qui
rapportent énormément d'argent parce qu’apparemment faire
un clone, ça coûte de l'argent. Le délire du clonage aurait commencé
peu de temps après la Seconde Guerre Mondiale, quand
les Hommes politiques ont commencé à s'afficher avec des stars, que ce soit
du cinéma ou de la musique. Stars qu'ils pouvaient
contrôler puisque ce sont des clones
sauf qu'ils se souviennent pas d'être des clones. Donc
ils sont très dociles.... J'sais pas si vous avez vu
le film "The Island" : par exemple, dans le film ils utilisent les clones,
en fait les gens riches se font cloner. Pour que si
ils aient un problème et qu'il aient besoin d'une greffe ou quoi,
et ben ils prennent à leurs clones en fait. Voilà...
Une sorte de sécurité sociale, une assurance
vie... Jusque-là ça se tient un peu. C'est là où
ça part un peu en couilles !! On a trahis Marshall
a testé un cocktail expérimental de toutes les drogues
réunies ! Il accuse principalement la famille
royale d'Angleterre, de faire partie du coup.
Apparemment, Elisabeth serait
l'une des pires.
Elle leur ferait des trucs affreux comme par exemple,
les découper à l'épée pendant qu'ils hurlent !
Vous commencez à un peu moins aimer Donald Marshall...
Hé ! Respectez-le ! Okay ? C'est le premier clone qui a réussi à s'enfuir du complexe des Illuminatis. Okay ?
On lui doit le respect : c'est une putain de héros ce mec !!
Comment il a fait d'ailleurs pour réussir à s'enfuir du complexe des Illuminatis ?
Il a dû établir le meilleur plan de l'Histoire.
Un truc infaillible ! Les Illuminatis
ont eut peur de sa puissance !
Il est si malin Donald Marshall !
Il a chanté... C'est bon ?
Il a chan... C'est lui
qui le dit. Je n'invente rien. Donald Marshall
aurait chanté, comme ça, devant les Illuminatis.
Et... Enfin, il aurait chanté
des trucs qu'il a composé lui-même.Et les Illuminatis
auraient adoré ses musiques. Ils auraient donc arrêté
de maltraiter le pauvre Donald et auraient préféré
tirer profit de son talent pour la musique.
Tututu... Allez... Respectez-le hein...
Il aurait composé "Single ladies" de Beyoncé, "Unforgiven"
de Metallica, "You gonna go far kid"
de The Offspring et "Shut it down"
de Pitbull. Bon celle-la on s'en bat les couilles, j'avoue !
C'est ainsi que Donald Marshall regagne sa liberté.
Et n'est plus prisonnier des Illuminatis.
*Clap*Clap* Un vrai héros ! *Clap*Clap*
Il a fait des interviews, il a été contacté par
énormément de personnes. Il a même une fan-base qui lui a créé un site.
Alors c'est quoi la suite Lucas ?! Putain !
Calmez-vous... Votre star est peut-être morte
il y a de nombreuses années, mais les Illuminatis l'ont remplacée
par un clone ou par un sosie. Et vous n'y avez vu
que du feu ! Je vous propose d'enquêter sur ces Stars
qui auraient été remplacées, il y a des années, par un clone.
Puisqu'elles seraient en réalité mortes!
Premièrement, Avril
Lavigne !
Comment ça personne n'est fan d'elle en 2018 ?
Avril Lavigne se serait sucidée en
2003, après que ses parents aient
divorcé.
Les mecs vous auriez pas pu trouver une meilleure raison quand même ?
Elle aurait été remplacée par un sosie
du nom de Melissa. Alors pourquoi
chercher un sosie quand tu peux faire des clones, hein ?
Je sais pas. Mais bon.
Mais qu'est-ce qui a trahi Melissa alors qu'elle lui ressemble
comme deux gouttes d'eau ? Eh ben d'après les fans c'est son nez.
Effectivement, le nez... heu... de Avril
est différent du nez de Melissa !
... Bah c'est surtout
la photo, hein, qu'est différente, hein. Y en a une de face,
l'autre de profil. L'une les couleurs sont pas ouf,
l'autre les couleurs sont super, heu...leu...lumineuses. Ils auraient aussi
trouvé suspect que dans une des chansons de
Melissa du coup, hein ! Après la mort
de Avril ! Y ait une ligne qui dise :
Putaiiiinnn...mec c'est sûr elle parle d'Avril !
C'est sûr elle parle du jour où Avril est morte
et qu'elle a su qu'elle allait devoir prendre la place d'Avril.
C'est diiingue !
Ou alors elle parle de son chat, en**lé !
Les fans ont essayé de trouver une interview suspecte d'Avril Lavigne,
au Brésil. Où ses réponses aux questions
d'une journaliste qui croit à cette théorie sont un peu...
bizarres.
Menteuse ! On voit clairement que t'en a déjà entendu
parler ! Tu peux pas dire: "J'en ai pas entendu parler." alors que
c'est un buzz TOTAL depuis des années !
Huuuuuuuummmmmmmm...
Avril, ta réaction est étrange ! Mais peut-être est-ce la
réaction normale quand un journaliste te dit que tu es un
clone ! Alors que c'est toi ! Haha ! Bon !
C'en est tout pour Avril, ou devrais-je dire, Melissa !
Oh ! On passe à quelqu'un d'autre tiens,
ça m'a soulé !
OK !
On passe à Eminem ! Eminem dans les années 90,
après le buzz total de son album
"Slim Shady" aurait été approché par les
Illuminatis comme bon nombre de Stars après un buzz
total ! Mais il aurait refusé, il aurait décliné leur offre.
Oh nan ! Les Illuminatis l'auraient donc tué dans
un accident de voiture. C'est souvent ça en plus ! Je vous
assure ! C'est souvent un accident de voiture ! Et ils l'auraient remplacé
par un clone cette fois ! Voyons
voir ses différences ! Aaaaaaaaah...
La courbe de ses cheveux aurait changée.
Bah comme pour beaucoup d'hommes hein ! Quand tu vieillis, oui !
La courbe de tes cheveux change un peu !
Je suis désolé de vous avoir rappelé que votre calvicie est...est bien réelle.
Et pourquoi ils ont entouré l'oreille ?
L'oreille est différente ? Bah attends elle est carrément pareille
mec hein ! Il a des gros lobes en plus Eminem !
OK ! Ah je comprends pas l'argument, là. C'est quoi ?
C'est l'espace entre le sourcil et les cheveux, c'est ça ?
Je sais même pas, ça me fatigue !
Attention, alerte ! Les clones des fois, auraient des bugs !
Et apparemment le clone d'Eminem aurais eu un bug
En plein live à la télé le 7 septembre 2013
Ou le 9 juillet 2013, c'est peut-être la date
en américain, je sais pas. Haha !
J'adore
Il est éclaté mon gars
Il est ÉCLATÉ sa mère
olalalalaaa
C'est le pire truc qui peut t'arriver en live à la télé
Ensuite il passe un peu des extraits de ses songs
Et quand ça revient sur lui j'veux voir la gueule qui fait
est-ce qu'il est normal ou pas
Woooaaaaaa
Oh là là là !
C'est horrible !
Et est-ce que c'est bel et bien un clone qui a beugé
Ou alors est-ce que c'est juste Eminem
Qui a décidé de prendre en peu de drogue
Avant cette interview et cette soirée géniale  ??
On ne sait paaas
Ce qui est drôle c'est qu'il a remis ça il y a pas si longtemps
Dans une autre interview
Je sais pas si c'est un live cette fois-ci
Mais il étais encore une fois dans une interview
Y'a un problème avec les interviews je crois
ça fait beuger le cerveau d'Eminem
Et il a eu une phase exactement comme celle qu'on a vu avant
Holy shiiiiit
J’avoue la c'est quand même bizarre
Surtout ce qui est bizarre c'est qu'après avoir fait sa phase là
Il a pas fait un ptit sourire en mode
"haha c'que j'ai fait c’était un  peu drôle et tout"
Il garde son sérieux de OUF
Ici rien d'alarmant
Une petite blague d'Eminem
Ou un petit rail de quelque chose avant
Alors atteeeeends
Ah là j'aime bien ça
Celle là elle est bien
Connaissez vous les Beatles,
Célèbre groupe Anglais
Comme Elizabeth II
C'est pas un hasard ça hein
Ils ont fait danser nos parents
ils les ont fait kiffer
des modèles, mon gars, des superstars
MAIS apparemment Paul McCartney serait mort dans un accident de voiture
Encore !
En 1966
C'est la rumeur qui circulait à Londres à cette époque
Sauf que McCartney en 2018 et toujours bel et bien en vie
Alors l'information serait-elle fausse
Ou serait-elle vraie
Paul McCartney aurait été remplacé par un sosie
Et non pas un clone !
Apparemment ce serait le MI5, Le service de renseignement Britannique
Qui aurait imposé au label de remplacer Paul McCartney par un sosie
Pour éviter de nombreux suicides chez les fans des Beatles
J'avoue ça me parait plus logique
Que ce soit le label des beatles qui ce soit dit
"Attend ils génèrent vraiment énormément d'argent
Si lui il est mort c'est relou quand même
on va peut-être en mettre un autre
Comme ça ça continue de faire de la thune
La rumeur prend beaucoup d'importance après la sortie de l'album "Abbey Road" en 1969
Parce-que sur la pochette du disque
La configuration de la scène regorgerait de preuves
Montrant que Paul McCartney serait mort
Alors attention
Déjà lui il est pieds nus
Comme les personnes enterrées en Inde
A côté de lui Ringo Starr est habillé en noir
Qui est la couleur de la mort en Occident
John Lennon quant à lui est habillé en blanc
Qui est la couleur de la mort en Orient
Je trouve ça drôle quand même
Mec juste il s'habillent en noir ou en blanc par-ce-que c'est cool, c'est stylé
George Harrison ferme la marche et son jean témoignerait du fait qu'il s'est chargé de la mise en terre
Il (Harrison) est le seul ne pas marcher du même pas
Il a également un cigarette dans la main droite
Alors qu'il est gaucher
Peut-être parce qu'ils ont choisi le profil droit pour faire leur photo
Et que si il l'a tenait en main gauche elle ne se voyait pas
PEUT-ÊTRE
Apres je balance ça, je veux pas faire de dramas
De plus la plaque d'immatriculation de la voiture en arrière plan
LMW 28 IF
Signifierait "Living McCartney would be 28 if.."
Paul McCartney vivant aurait 28 ans si..
Et au fond à droite le van sombre
Serait un corbillard
Eh franchement elle est pas mal celle là quand même
Ca va loin j'aime bien
Certains fans auraient même entendu John Lennon dire
"I buried Paul
Ce qui veut dire "J'ai enterré Paul"
Dans la derniere partie du song "Strawberry fields forever"
John Lennon s'est expliqué en disant
qu'il n'a pas dit "i buried Paul" mais qu'il a dit "cranberry sauce"
Ca me fait marrer c'est fou
Ce qui n'a vraiment rien a voir
Les amis c'est la fin de cette vidéo sur les illuminatis et le clonage
J'espère qu'elle vous aura plus
J'avoue j'aime bien la théorie du "des stars sont décédés
alors on les remplace par des sosies ni vu ni connu comme ça elles continuent de faire de l'argent
Maintenant pourquoi des stars ont été remplacées par des clones et pourquoi d'autres non
Alors qu'elles faisaient elles aussi énormément d'argent
Genre Micheal Jackson, 2pac, Amy Winehouse
Du coup juste ça, ça suffit à discrédité toute cette thèse des clones et des sosies
Mais bon c'est quand même rigolo
Et ça se trouve moi aussi je suis un clone
Aller a très vite dans une prochaine vidéo pour parler d'autres théories
J'en ai d'autres sous la mains que je kiff
J'ai trop hâte de vous parlez de tout ca
Jvous fais des bisous, a très vite !
Sous-titres par : les gens dans la description :)